now guaranteed wide awake here in the
studio is today's guest Patrick Cowden
Patrick spent years as a high-flying
manager and he's now a best-selling
author on the topic of work and
corporate culture Patrick thanks very
much for joining us thank you now
firstly it seems that young people want
to have fun in the workplace and the
older generation seems intent on
continuing to work is that really the
case well I think fun is probably not
exactly the right word I think they're
searching for sense sense of purpose and
meaning and the interesting thing is
that connects both generations because
the older generation is looking for the
same thing they don't want to just quit
and stop everything their life purpose
has been about they want to continue so
I think connecting those two potentials
of the young the vitality and the older
with the wisdom that's an interesting
challenge for the future could that
potentially be also a nice way of
putting a spin on things for example we
do see a lot of young people who are
stuck in this vicious circle of unending
internships and then perhaps the older
generation who simply don't stop working
because they can't make ends meet
perhaps well I think you know jumping
from one internship to the next is a way
of expressing that search you know a
search for meaningfulness and I think
all the generations have had that but
the younger generation is a little bit
bolder about sticking to it longer and I
think that the older generation as they
can recognize the potential is coming
from from Gen Y I think it would
activate the older generation to to go
further and and to give more than they
have before and I think it's the
challenge to the organization's to find
in an environment that can activate that
for all the generations in the company
absolutely German companies have been
sounding the alarm about the the
potential of skilled workers retiring
and they're not having the young
professionals coming in to fill those
jobs so how do we retract it attract and
retain young talent well I think that's
one of the elements is attracting the
talent but I think the other element is
activating everything that's there
you know if 85 percent of people aren't
activated in quality and engaged the
bigger question for current organ
is not filling the smaller gap but
activating the bigger piece of the
organization across all generations men
and women everybody going further than
they've ever gone before that's fun
you've held leadership positions at
Deutsche Bank at Dell at Hitachi you're
somebody who knows what it's like to do
80-hour workweeks and have back-to-back
meetings for example so how did you
manage it personally well it's always a
challenge and I think over the years
that was eight years ago at Dell where
was the worst you know you realize that
everywhere in the world all the
different places I go you see that same
mechanism focus on profit focus on
results and it comes at a price
we lose connection to the things that
are most important to us and at some
point you get sick you get burnout and
that's not in the interests of the
company so the organizations need to
understand is there a way to change the
environment so that we activate the
goodness and not the badness and how
should they do that what needs to change
in corporate culture do you think well I
think understanding the drivers around
people in the quality of our teamwork
underneath all the cultural layers
elements like respect and trust and
appreciation they breed a strength and a
health that it's not about the hours we
do but the quality of how we do those
hours if we can come home with
motivation and engagement and feel
really good about the day that's a
quality that's not at the top of the
list of most companies today I think
that's the future of where we need to go
let's talk a little bit international
then we know that in Japan that there
can be quite a rigid working culture
than say for example here in Germany
that France can be hierarchical why is a
good place to work well I think the
workplace of the future crosses all
those different boundaries it's not just
oh Bob I am you know one part of one
country I think these cultures as they
come together in the globalization we
see a huge human potential underneath
that respect element that trust element
and I think if organizations can connect
that together that's where we want to
work we want to work where this quality
of teamwork is at a high level and our
engagement goes up every single day and
not the opposite effect that we see out
there today
that almost no one really wants to give
everything for their team or their
company anymore there's a brighter
future that we can strive for
I like that future better thank you very
much for joining us Patrick cowden Thank
You Helen